let's get some insight now into the iran
issue other situations around the globe
joining us tonight secretary of state
mike pompeo mr secretary thanks for
being here brett it's great to be with
you thank you
just listen to your boss say that you
need to go to the u.n and get these
snapback sanctions
uh you've said that you have every
expectation that the u.n security
council will do that what makes you
think that
yeah brett i'll head up to new york
tomorrow tomorrow afternoon i'll meet
with the u.n security council president
and then the
secretary general will provide
notification of the snap back and then
30 days from now
all the sanctions that were in place
will resume they've been temporarily
paused because of the
ridiculous nuclear deal and the world
will be safer placed the
iranians won't have the chance to have
russian air defense systems chinese
tanks all the things that pose risk and
instability in the middle east
the gulf states are all excited about
israel is excited about it it'll reduce
their risk
and it'll make america safer too so when
china or russia refuse
is the administration going to hold them
accountable with sanctions too
absolutely we we've already done that
when we've seen any country violate our
current sanctions the current american
sanctions
we've held every nation accountable for
that we'll do the same thing with
respect to the broader u.n security
council sanctions as well
what does it say when you tried to get
the arms embargo extended
on iran that not one european ally stood
with the united states
yeah brett it's really unfortunate it
makes the european people
less safe you know privately these
countries all tell me that they want
this arms embargo extended they want
they don't want iran to have these
weapons but they refuse to do the
courageous thing the morally right thing
and vote in support of extending it
all for some holy grail of the jcpoa
uh but the world needs to know president
trump's made clear we're going to do the
right thing we're going to keep the
world safer we hope
that the europeans will come to see it
this way as well but that
will whether the europeans do or not has
never stopped president trump from
protecting america and keeping us all
safe so in that
vein i mean can the u.s work with the
europeans
when it comes to iran well we've found
places where we can do that already so
we've worked on
in the straits of our moves where we've
jointly done good work to
deter aggression there so we've found
pockets and places where we can we have
the same objectives
they just are wedded to this crazy
nuclear deal
they're trying to hang on to it
president trump's made clear they're not
going to have a nuclear weapon they
should
come alongside us and do the right thing
for the world and you know this is now
the fifth anniversary the first element
of the jcpoa to expire
the islamic republic of iran continues
to be enormously anti-semitic wanting to
wipe israel from the face of the earth
the largest state sponsor of terror
we're doing the right thing we're going
to get these u.n sanctions put back in
place
and the world will be safer just so
people at home know the jcp
jcpoa is the iran nuclear deal do you
think
the europeans like the germans want to
sell weapons to iran
no i don't think that's it at all i
think they
have some odd notion that somehow uh
this is actually protecting and
preserving
some risk that the iranians will begin
their nuclear weapons program it hasn't
proven to do that
you know we've now through the sanctions
we put in place tonight over 200 billion
dollars
to the islamic republic of iran that's
fewer dollars to put
missiles in place that could threaten
places like london or brussels or
germany i i think the people of europe
understand this is the right thing i
think their leaders do too
we'll lead the way do you think the
snapback if in fact it goes forward
essentially kills the jcpoa that that
deal is done and it cannot be
resurrected
even if there is a president biden
brett i know this i know that the
resolutions that were put in place and
have been in place for
goodness over a decade now will be back
in effect and so yes i think it's the
case that all of the
elements all of the things that were
waived all of the things that secretary
kerry and wendy's sherman
have wrought upon the risk they've
created in the middle east and more out
of places
will no longer be the case you mentioned
secretary kerry last night he spoke at
the dnc one of the things he talked
about was iran i'm going to play some
things
have you react to them quickly here's
the first one on iran
for the eight years of the obama biden
administration we led by example
we eliminated the threat of an iran with
a nuclear weapon what about that
that's just false uh they didn't lead by
example they led from behind that was
their
that was their motto president trump
leads from the front he's prepared to
take the courageous stands
uh they didn't stop iran from having a
nuclear weapon indeed they provided
billions and billions of dollars so that
iran could continue their nuclear
enrichment program and
protect themselves from attack they they
put themselves on a pathway to a nuclear
weapon
that's what the deal did we're going to
prevent that pathway from continuing
john kerry on russia donald trump
pretends russia didn't attack our
elections
and now he does nothing about russia
putting a bounty on our troops
response so two pieces to that first
there's been no president tougher on
russia whether that's our defense
buildup whether it's the
uh the work that we've done to provide
our weapons systems to the ukrainian
people to defend themselves remember
john kerry and and vice president biden
refused
to do that i'm confident that the
russians would rather have that policy
denying the ukrainian's weapons we've
we've been tough on russia we've
sanctioned
hundreds of russians for their malign
activity i think this administration
takes a backseat to no one with respect
to standing up for america protecting
our security and getting it right
with respect to russia whether that's
russian efforts in afghanistan or in
syria
or in ukraine we heard the president
answer this but in your talks with the
russians did you bring up the alleged
bounties on u.s troops in afghanistan
i did i've spoken with my counterpart
foreign minister lavrov about that i've
made clear to them that
threatening american soldiers not only
in afghanistan but anyplace else
is something that there will be true
costs for all right here is uh
colin powell on trust take a listen
he will trust our diplomats and our
intelligence community
not the flattery of dictators and
despots
response i have a lot of respect for
general powell i've known him for a long
time
this is a president who when i was the
ci director
i always valued the information that i
provided him and now as
america's most senior diplomat i've
watched him listen
help me get to the right place in terms
of how he was thinking about to deliver
on
his foreign policy i watched him value
these people in important ways so
i'm not sure what it was general powell
was speaking to you there
last thing one thing that has not come
up a lot so far and i guess last
night was foreign policy we'll hear
maybe it may come up again but
china has not come up is that do you
believe in opening
for republicans next week on that issue
and what you're doing
you know i've been terribly surprised
that the democrats haven't talked about
foreign policy enough
with no mentions of china the single
greatest challenge to the united states
over the next years the single greatest
threat to the united states comes
from the chinese communist party donald
trump called it early he talked about it
during his campaign in 2015 and again in
2016 and now for
three and a half years we've imposed
cost on china in a way
that has protected the american people
from this threat and when they
uh refused to acknowledge the wuhan
virus when they said
uh we're gonna cover this up we're gonna
allow people to travel across the world
in spite of the fact that we know
it presents a threat president trump is
aiming to hold them accountable
for the enormous loss of life all across
the world and the trillions of dollars
in economic harm
that the chinese communist party allowed
to permeate
all throughout the world mr secretary we
always appreciate your time there's
always kinds of
more questions that we want to ask but
we appreciate all the time you give us
and
safe travels to the u.n thank you brett
have a good evening